wall e
goo
me
t
私が日本に来てから3年半になりました
私がどこの出身で
そこでどんな人たちがどんな暮らしをしているのか
そして日本のいい頃のにどのくらいかかるのかということに持つ人にたくさんいました
私が質問肉体終わると彼らは決まって日本と全然違うとか
とても遠いと言います
さて倒産についての話を続ける前に
私がシェリアにいたときの話をします
皆さん
シェリアで今とてもひどい度状況になっていることをご存じだと思います
政府軍が普通の人々を台風することは
6地上的に起きています
理由は様々です
政治勝機をほんのはずさ
その他どんなものでも
私も
ある日突然
捕まりました
それは大学があるとこの街に戻る前日のことでした
私は l 体が入った買ったので出発を1日怒らせるにして
服屋ハァハァか用意してくれた美味しいご飯を荷物に詰めました
出発の日の朝の5時ぐらいに
ハァハァとリモートの
怯えた光栄で目が覚めました起きて政府軍が村を包囲してるわ
弟達と知り合いの家に月
私がリビングルームに行くと
ロートたちがすでに準備終わって私は思っていましたが私と一緒に逃げないと分かると
度裏のドアから出て行きました
残った父と母
リモートとまだ幼い弟と私は
アイスタッチが私たちのエディをスムーズに確認できるようにドアの前にまたって待ち
ました
早く終われば私はまたねルールと思っていました
父がドアを開けたとき
最初に私が見たものは警官の白い引けとそれ c 紺の制服でした
彼の周りには
ヘイシーがたくさんいました
乳が私たちの id を足すと彼は
id と
彼が持っていた神
を見比べ始めました
その時彼は私を見て彼が私が
徴兵免除を送ってることについて聞きました
ん
私は免除の紙を渡すと
彼はちらりと見て
隣にいた兵士に私行為ました
これどうも
見世物だろう
兵士が
あろうことか完全に彼に同意しました
それが穴が1になると分かった瞬間でした
彼は
私を呼び指すと兵士が私の腕を掴みました
警官が母に
心配するな
30分で確認はすぐ割ると言いました
兵士は私の右腕を引っ張りながら
靴を履けどう言っていました入った時私が思い出したのは
あるサンダルのことです
姉がー
最小の大砲の時入っていって
3回の大鵬の時にもあれを探して入っていったサンダルです
私は兄がその3だろう
入って一定2回ともうう12牢獄から出たという事実を覚えておくために
そのサンダルを履いていくことを決めました
ん
でもここは
何もしなくても
捕まえられ号を受け
死んでしまう人がたくさんいるシェリアでしたっ
死と隣り合わせの道城でした
なんでもいいから何かにすがりたかったのです
希望のサンダルと名前を付けていてみました
変だったって思うでしょ
私は腕を後ろに縛られ目隠しをされ
トラックの荷台の中に入れられました
たくさんの人がよると分かった分かりましたが話すことを許されず
車は走り続けましたん
長い長いそしてつらい時間でしたん
予約彼らは
私たちを2台から出して暑い夏の太陽の下で
みんなおかべ建物の壁の前に立てせました
建物の中から行為と声がしました
中に入ると
警官が私に
お前は何してるんだ同期きました
大学の学生ですと答える答えると
彼はさらにお前やお前の家族を守るために本体に入らないのか
遠いました
うーん
うんが私をここに連れて来た分
お前を守るなんてとんでもね
兵士に腕を掴まれ
たくさんの人が l 部屋につきました
目隠しを外すと
私の30分の旅が始まりました
30分なんて誰かがそんなことを言えたんでしょ
あの警官が母に30分 s ぐぅ割ると言っていました
それは2012年7月16日のことでした
次のに
兵士タッチが私たちを重宝し分に連れて行きました
そこに着くと一人ずつ小さな部屋に分けられて私は縦に見えた幅1メートルの部屋に
入れられました
そこには私より先に
3人の男とまだ13歳になっていない子どもが2人いました
狭すぎたので
私たちは交代で立ったり座ったりしました
他の日よも合わせるとここには40人がいましたが
明日20人でられることを
並進が言いました
このニュースで明日を待つ私たちは私たちの夜は非常にゆっくり過ぎました
朝になりヘイシーが来て
沢山の名前の中に呼ばれるの祈るように待ちましたか
とうとう呼ばれませんです
私は小さな部屋に一人になりました
また次の日に
また別のキム所に連れて行かれました
私は今でもあの時間に続く階段のみんなにおよ覚えています
良い子がドア開けるまでその匂いが何なのか分かりませんでした
床が血で染まっていました
暖房装置にくくりつけられ
動きもなく
転がっている人たちからでたちです
通路の終わりには
ドアが開けたままにしてあり
何百ものの人を
詰め込まれていました
大切なさんだろう思って
どこに行けばいいのか分からず歩きも割れました
なんとか大きい部屋を見つけましたが
即にも駅ができない
駅ができていない
死ぬ間際この子供や音のがいました
なんとかこの場所を系れようと
しましたが
すぐ時間後
部屋を変えた方がいいと思いそこを出て
これはすぎて多くが見えない部屋に行きました
その部屋を選んであるようは正直自分でもよくわかりません
入り口から2人ぐらいしか見えませんでしたが中に入るとたくさんの人を
見えるようになります
縦5メートル幅1メートルほどの部屋の端っこに入ってソワレました
目が暗さに慣れると
の割のふとの顔が見えてきました
そして
突然
壁に爪で彫られた文字海へました
色には
こう書いてありました
1983年
8月7日真実の言葉
私は不当に捕らえられてたが
ついに
明日解放される
誰かが20人も20人以上も前に彫ったものでした
その壁のメッセージのついに明日解放される以外の部分は
1センチほどの墓さで深く深く掘られていました
血統毎日毎日出られることを信じて
何度も何度もなぞり続けたのだよ
その壁ぬその瞬間
時間を超えたつながれが持つ違う
に気づきました
その壁のが siege の
を見た後
この長くをひどい日々から抜け出してやるって言うととついもない
気分かは行ってきました
その人がこの部屋に入っていたということ以外は何も知りません
彼は
太陽の光を阿部れませんでしたが
私の荒れ果てた心に
光をくれました
彼は金の爪で
この今黒てる製薬なことは終わると教えてくれました
日々が過ぎ
私は明るいところも暗いところもたくさんの場所に移動をさせられていたさせられてい
ましたが
彼が教えてくれた某決して忘れませんでした
さらに指が過ぎ
私はオリーブの木が地平線まで続いた畑が見える窓のある場所につきました
その畑を見て
雨が降る前にここから出たいと思いました
シェアでの雨は冬がきたことを意味するからです
そして
3ヶ月
18の異なる場所でそこした後
ついに解放されました
まるで映画のように
その日に雨が降りました
私を迎えに来てくれた父のとなるよう
大切なサンダルを持って歩きながら
爪で書かれたまま政治が私に希望遅れました事を話しました
すると父は言い
ウィッグ目の前にいなくてもあなたは誰かの希望になれるんだよと言いました
さて
私が日本とシェリアの遠さについて話してたことに戻りましょう
シェルやは日本から遠すぎる
シェリアで今北てることは私たちに関係がないというのは間違っています
遠くないです無関係ではないです
だって今種類や人の私が日本で日本人の皆さんの前に立っています
世界の人と出来事はそんなが日あっています
それらは郷里を超え
時間を超え
この世界の誰かに影響を与えるかもしれません
たとえそれが
毎日の
西生活の自分の小さな決断や行動でも
自分が気づいてなくてもどんな小さいのことだと思っていても他の人にとっては
それは希望となったり
命を救うことさえあれます
もしあのカレーが爪でやのメッセージを怒らなかったら
今私もここにいなかったかもしれません
私たちは青こともない会ったこともないかもしれない
世界の誰かに影響を与える力を持っています
私たちは実は
多くの人の人生に影響を与え
世界を持っ
変えることができるんです
ありがとうございました